We predicted this would happen, but now it's
time to really get our hands sort of dirty
because the treasury led by Trump flunky.
Steven Minutian is officially refusing to
turn over Donald Trump's tax returns, which
were requested legally, uh, by Congressman
Richard Neil on the basis of a law from the
1920s, uh, in his role as chairman of the
house ways and means committee.
The reason why minutia is refusing to turn
over Trump's tax returns is exactly the reason
that we predicted, which is that the requests
from committee chairman Richard Neal quotes,
lacks a legitimate legislative purpose, which
minutian claims is required by the supreme
court in over to, in order to turn over tax
returns.
Unfortunately, it doesn't appear that that's
actually the case.
So I'm going to explain this all to you piece
by piece.
Uh, and what you have to remember is that
Stephen Minutian was advised by Trump's justice
department in terms of how to not provide
these tax returns.
The Trump justice department is led of course,
by none other than Attorney General William
Barr, a professional at covering up the misdeeds
of presidents of the United States.
So this is a loss.
If you were expecting that today, we would
get Donald Trump's tax returns, but it's completely
expected and it's now going to set off a legal
battle that could actually be positive in
a way, in the sense that it's going to put
Donald Trump's tax returns.
And more importantly, the fact that we haven't
seen them back in the news, which strategically
is good for Democrats because most Americans
want to see Donald Trump's taxes.
So that's the strategy.
Let's first go through the legality of this.
There's a law that's very clear.
Okay.
The law dates back to the 1920s, I think it's
24, but I'm going from memory.
And the law says that if you're a member of
the House and Senate, a house or Senate who
is on a tax writing committee and there are
a number of committees that have tax writing
privileges, you were able to legally request
the tax returns of any taxpayer and that the
IRS quote shall furnish them.
Period.
There are no caveats there.
There are no ifs, ands and buts.
You can request them if you're on one of those
committees and the IRS shall furnish them.
It doesn't allow for getting help from the
Justice Department to try to block the request.
Something which a president can try, but most
citizens would not be able to try to get the
Justice Department to help them block the
release of their tax returns.
But the one question about all of this was,
is there any precedent which says that if
you want to request the tax return from an
individual taxpayer on this basis using this
law, that you need to justify a legislative
purpose for the request.
If there is Richard Neil says the committee
is looking into whether mandatory audits of
sitting presidents are good policy.
So he's come up with a reason, a justification,
a legislative justification if indeed one
is needed.
Now, the truth is that claiming you need a
reason is pretty dubious.
And the reason that we know that's the case
is by looking at the law.
If you look at 26 us code subsection 61 oh
three, it doesn't say anything about a legislative
purpose.
It says just quote upon written request from
the chairman of the committee on House on
ways and means of the House of Representatives,
the chairman of the Committee on finance of
the Senate or the chairman of the joint committee
on taxation, the secretary of the treasury.
That means shelf furnished such committee
with any return or return information specified
in such request, except that any return or
return information which can be associated
with or otherwise identified directly or indirectly
a particular taxpayer shall be furnished to
such committee only when sitting in closed
executive session unless such taxpayer otherwise
consents in writing to such disclosure.
So what it says is that it has to be submitted,
uh, um, uh, privately, right in executive
session, unless the taxpayer says it's okay
for it to be made more widely available.
It says nothing about legislative purpose.
Minutian has come up with a viable explanation,
but it's nowhere in the law.
It says that the secretary of the Treasury
shall furnish, not secretary of the Treasury
will analyze whether they believe there is
a legislative purpose and devaluate whether
in their opinion it is a legitimate legislative
purpose.
This is arguably another act of obstruction.
If Trump directed the justice department to
help the treasury not follow the law, it is
another instance and they're already 14 others,
which we'll talk about later.
It is another instance of obstructing the
process of justice.
It's another check box, so to speak, in the
list of things Nixon resigned over which Donald
Trump has also done.
So that's the legal side of it.
Then there's the strategy piece.
Seeing Trump's tax returns is very popular
with Americans.
It goes beyond just Democrats.
So simply keeping this in the news is probably
a good strategy, particularly as a reminder,
as 2020 sort of heats up that Donald Trump
still hasn't released his taxes and is actively
using his Justice Department and the Treasury
to keep those tax returns secrets.
So even if this fails to get Trump's tax returns
over to the house ways and means committee,
which it very well may because this is an
administration that just ignores subpoenas,
ignores requests and they don't seem to be
suffering any consequences for that.
Uh, even if it doesn't achieve that, it still
is likely a useful thing for Democrats in
2020 just as a reminder that we've still not
seeing those tax returns and Donald Trump
is going even more out of his way then he
has at any previous point to prevent those
tax returns from going public.
Last caveat.
If you think that the tax returns, if we saw
them, would expose criminality by Trump?
I don't think so.
I think the most likely scenario is the taxes
would expose that Donald Trump is not nearly
as wealthy as he claims to be.
A, and maybe some of this manipulation of
property values, uh, higher when it's advantageous
and lower when it's advantageous.
But I don't think you're going to get the
bombshell criminality.
Some are are sort of token B disagree though.
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at [inaudible] and the show
is on Twitter at
David Pakman show